we are told a restaurant owner installed
a new automated drink machine the
machine is designed to dispense 530
milliliters of liquid on the
medium-sized setting the owner suspects
that the machine may be dispensing too
much in medium drinks they decide to
take a sample of 30 medium drinks to see
if the average amount is significantly
greater than 500 milliliters what are
appropriate hypotheses for their
significance test and they actually give
us four choices here I'll scroll down a
little bit so that you can see all of
the choices so like always pause this
video and see if you can have a go at it
okay now let's do this together so let's
just remind ourselves what a null
hypothesis is and what an alternative
hypothesis is one way to view a null
hypothesis this is the hypothesis where
things are happening as expected
sometimes people will describe this as
the no difference hypothesis it'll often
have a statement of equality where the
population parameter is equal to a value
where the value is what people whereas
kind of assuming all along the
alternative hypothesis this is a claim
where if you have evidence to back up
that claim that would be new news you
are saying hey there's something
interesting going on here there is a
difference and so in this context the no
difference we would say the null
hypothesis would be we would care about
the population parameter and here we
care about the average amount of drink
dispensed in the medium setting so the
population parameter there would be the
mean and that the mean would be equal to
five hundred thirty milliliters because
that's what the the drink machine is
supposed to do and then the alternative
hypothesis this is what the owner fears
is that the mean actually might be
larger than that larger than 530
milliliters and so let's see which of
these choices is this well these first
two choices are talking about proportion
but it's really the average amount that
we're talking about we see it up here
they decide to take a sample of 30
medium drinks to see if the average
amount they're not talking about
proportions here they're talking about
averages and in this case we're talking
about estimating the population
parameter the
population mean for how much drink is
dispensed on that setting and so this
one is looking like this right over here
only these two are deep in dealing with
the mean and the difference between this
one and this one is this says the mean
is greater than 530 milliliters and that
indeed is the owners fear and this over
here this alternative hypothesis is that
the that its dispensing on average less
than 500 30 milliliters but that's not
what the owner is afraid of and so
that's not the kind of the news that
we're trying to find some evidence for
so I would definitely pick choice C
let's do another example the National
Sleep Foundation recommends that
teenagers aged 14 to 17 years old get at
least 8 hours of sleep per night for
proper health and wellness a statistics
class at a large high school suspects
that students at their school are
getting less than 8 hours of sleep on
average to test their theory they
randomly sample 42 of these students and
ask them how many hours of sleep they
get per night the mean from this sample
the mean from the sample is 7.5 hours
here's their alternative hypothesis the
average amount of sleep students at
their school get per night is what is an
appropriate ending to their alternative
hypothesis so pause this video and see
if you could think about that so let's
just first think about a good null
hypothesis so the null hypothesis is hey
there's actually no news here that
everything is what people were always
assuming and so the null the null
hypothesis here is that no the students
are getting at least eight hours of
sleep per night and so that would be
that remember we care about the
population of students and so and we
care about the population of students at
the school and so we would say well the
null hypothesis is that the parameter
for the students at that school the mean
amount of sleep that they're getting is
indeed greater than or equal to 8 hours
and a good clue for the alternative
hypothesis is when you see something
like this where they say a statistics
class at a large high school suspects so
they suspect that things might be
different than what people have always
been assuming or actually what's good
for students and so they suspect that
students at their school are getting
less than eight hours of sleep on
average and so they suspect that the
population parameter the population mean
for their school is actually less than
eight hours and so if you wanted to
write this out in words the average
amount of sleep students at their school
get per night is less than eight hours
now one thing to watch out for is one
you want to make sure you're getting the
right parameter sometimes it's often a
population mean sometimes it's a
population proportion but the other
thing that sometimes folks get get stuck
up on but the other thing that sometimes
confuses folks is well we are measuring
is that we are calculating a statistic
from a sample here we're calculating the
sample mean but that the sample
statistics are not what should be
involved in your hypotheses your
hypotheses are claims about your
population that you care about here the
population is the students at the high
school